distressing scenes in copenhagen
fans and players watched on in horror as
denmark star christian eriksen
collapsed in their euro 2020 game
against finland
his teammates formed a human shield
around him as he was given cpr on the
pitch for several minutes
before being taken away on a stretcher
the match was suspended with those left
in the stadium fearing the worst
but then more positive news a photograph
emerged
showing the midfielder raising his hand
as he was carried off
it was then confirmed by the tournament
organizers that eriksen was stable and
conscious
in hospital denmark's football
association said their players were able
to communicate directly with eriksen
and the decision was taken by both teams
to restart the game
which finland went on to win one nil
german national tv zdf
reported that it was a christian eriksen
himself
that gave his green light to his players
that said please go on play that game
erickson is 29 years old and plays for
the italian champions
into milan inter's team physician has
said eriksen never contracted kovid 19
has no medical conditions that he's
aware of and has passed every medical
exam since joining from tottenham
in january last year ericsson remains in
hospital and is undergoing tests
david stokes al jazeera